we really shouldn't be doing this Adams
argued it's fine it's just a test his
fellow researcher Burton retorted in
protest the container procedures for
scp-914 come with a very specific
warning not to test biological matter in
it if anyone had found out what we were
doing we would both be fired or Worse
dosed up with amnestics and left on the
sidewalk somewhere with no clue who we
were Burton rolled their eyes Adam's
concern was hardly unfounded but when
they had discussed the idea earlier he'd
seemed open to it then again it was only
a hypothetical back then now it was
getting closer to becoming reality look
aren't you tired of what we do here
Burton argued indignantly so many of the
tests we run end up with dead d-class
Personnel blood everywhere or just end
up creating new anomalies that will just
only go on to cause more people to die
I'm sick of it I don't think this course
of action is the best solution to that
though their colleague urged why not
scp-2800 is one of the few anomalies
either of us have ever encountered that
we can categorically consider to be good
he's not some heartless monster or
vengeful Cosmic deity he just wants to
do the right thing I already mentioned
it to him he's more than happy to
undergo the change and what if it kills
him Adams asked no what if it works
Burton responded sidestepping that
possibility entirely worst case scenario
he might not survive sure but best case
we could turn an ineffectual would-be
superhero into a tool to do some real
lasting good the pair of researchers
went back and forth until ultimately
Adams conceded it was hard to deny that
throwing any number of other scps into
the Clockwork refinement machine known
as scp-914 would easily yield far more
destructive results but scp-2800 was as
Burton rightfully pointed out a being of
well-meaning intense
if any average person were to wake up to
find their body had developed
characteristics consistent with that of
a saguaro cactus they'd likely seek out
immediate medical assistance but when
that happened to Daniel McIntyre he
immediately sought to use his Newfound
condition and the anomalous abilities it
granted him to offer assistance to any
person that needed it as the superhero
cactus man the spiked Menace
unfortunately when intervening in
situations Daniel proved himself to be
somewhat ineffectual as a hero although
this didn't deter him from trying now
housed in containment under the
designation
scp-2800 cactus man still continued to
offer assistance to the staff of the SCP
Foundation his behavior came as the
result of a few diagnosed psychological
conditions particularly his hero complex
a deep-rooted desire to help others no
matter the personal cost to Daniel
himself and it was this part of him that
caused scp-2800 to wholeheartedly agree
to researcher Burton's test unaware that
the experiment had not been sanctioned
by The Wider Foundation over here cactus
man asked as he stepped into the booth
labeled intake following researcher
Adam's directions that's perfect 2800
the researcher replied offering a thumbs
up before he turned away hiding his look
of concern shall we start with the
one-to-one setting researcher Burton the
hell with that Burton scoff we've got
maybe one attempt at this before
security notices he's out of his cell
and come here to find out what we're up
to we go big or we go home I'm setting 9
14 to very fine Burton Strode over to
the machine and threw the dial to the
highest of its five settings turning the
key below it wound the mainspring and
the entire device churned into life the
door to the intake Booth sliding shot
gears were spinning and grinding the
complex Contraption of over 8 million
moving parts starting its refinement
process belts pulleys gears Springs and
scp-914's other Clockwork Parts All
Began clicking and clacking while
scp-2800 stood in the intake Booth
growing more and more uneasy at all the
noise this strange machine was making
although the foundation had little idea
how its refinement process worked
scp-914 seemed to take any object placed
within its intake compartment and
disassemble recreate improve or destroy
the item depending on the setting its
control knob was switched to rough
completely obliterated an intake object
on a molecular level reducing it to
little more than dust coarse dismantle
the target into its base components
while one to one replaced it with a
similar item of matching design size and
quality the next setting up fine would
improve upon the base item although
usually without granting it any
anomalous properties and very fine well
you can figure it out from there you're
smart the last time a living being had
been placed in scp-914 on the very fine
set it had been a d-class and the
results were catastrophic a massive
containment failure numerous casualties
including the test subject since then no
testing of biological matter was
permitted in scp-914 but Burton was
convinced that scp-2800s in a need to
help people his deep-seated hero complex
and generally kind nature would mean
that the outcome was worth breaking the
rules
scp-914 was ticking and worrying the
noises of its components getting louder
and louder with each passing second so
loud in fact that it drowned out the
approaching clump of foundation issue
boots freeze hands in the air yelled one
of the security team as they burst into
research cell 109-b where the machine
was housed the pair of guards assigned
to watch it laid tied up and unconscious
on the floor both researcher Burton and
Adams threw their hands up as instructed
struck with panic at being caught in the
act the foundation security Personnel
moved in restraining them clasping
handcuffs tightly around the two
researchers wrists suddenly the noise of
the machine stopped the guards all
turned their attention to scp-914 racing
their weapons training them on the
output Booth with no idea what was about
to step out timidly as the compartment
door slid open cactus man slowly emerged
looking around confused as far as Burton
could tell from looking
scp-2800 didn't appear to be any
different he cursed atoms under his
breath irrationally believing that he'd
somehow change the machine setting to
one to one during all the commotion that
is until one of the guards approached
cactus man to restrain him as the
security officer moved to cuff him
scp-2800's arm whipped around as if of
its own accord with the speed and
precision of someone with far more
hand-to-hand combat training that Daniel
had ever received cactus man gently yet
firmly swatted the foundation scarred's
hands away and turned him around it had
been so
easy so instinctive that scp-2800 looked
even surprised himself barely able to
believe the movements of his own prickly
plant-based body the guard tried to
raise his arms again only to find he
couldn't it was completely numb in fact
everywhere scp-2800 had touched while
deflecting him was the same a series of
long sharp Cactus needles from Daniel
had been embedded in the security
officer's uniform piercing through his
clothing and skin all the way to his
muscles and yet it was painless he could
hardly feel any of the sharp protrusions
cactus man had disabled him with such
Effectiveness that the pain didn't even
register his spines implanted in the
guard's body like acupuncture needles
then seeing what he had done with an
instinctive flick of his wrist
scp-2800 made the spikes withdraw from
the officer and they shot back through
the air reattaching themselves to his
body following the incident and a Severe
reprimand for their unauthorized use of
scp-914 researcher Burton was assigned
to reassess
scp-2800's new improved abilities the
goal behind his investigation was to
determine whether cactus man had now
been rendered a more useful asset for
the foundation given he had retained his
need to offer help to others they were
looking to make use of him sure enough
the existing anomalous abilities Daniel
had exhibited before his refinement
seemed to have become much more
formidable Powers
scp-2800 had greater control over the
growing of his prickly spines as shown
when he first emerged from scp-914 not
only could he detach them at will as he
could before but he seemingly gained an
instinctive power to launch them as
high-speed projectiles neither recall
them or regrow missing spines at an
accelerated rate on top of that his
reflexes seemed to have greatly improved
as had his fighting prowess now able to
take on multiple adversaries without one
of them ever Landing a hit on him his
kaktakerous retention of water making
him able to survive on around one-third
of the water needed by an average human
male was also improved now scp-2800
could survive on next to no water
without drying out even a few drops was
enough to sustain him for an extended
period additionally no external Factor
could cause him to lose water his plant
cells were retaining even being in a
high temperature environment his
resistance to high temperatures typical
of many plants within the cacti family
had now evolved into scp-2800 being
fireproof he was unable to catch a light
even after direct exposure to Flame
additionally he had previously been able
to empathetically connect and
communicate with other cacti often
causing them to increase their water and
nutrient absorption now though cactus
man could cause his fellow spiked plants
to rapidly grow at an exponential rate
even producing cacti seeds that he could
command to grow the instant they made
contact with the soil or absorbed
moisture retained by his own body
despite the rules broken to refine him
the foundation now had their very own
plant-powered superhero ready to be
deployed at a moment's notice in the
event of a Containment Breach and more
than happy to help and it couldn't have
happened at a more opportune time over
the coming years the foundation granted
permission for cactus man to assist in
various recontainment efforts when
dangerous anomalies Broke Free of their
cells he ended up preventing the deaths
of a lot of the foundation's mobile task
force operatives as well as their
various Personnel purely by intervening
so they didn't have to put themselves in
Jeopardy however it was the eventual
defeat of scp-682 that allowed Daniel to
really make a name for himself as the
full-blown superhero he'd always wanted
to be nobody was sure how it happened
all that really mattered was the
Monstrous heart to destroy reptile was
loose again the crocodilian creature
famous for despising all other forms of
life had torn through the foundation
facility where it was being kept it left
a trail of Destruction in its wake
causing multiple subsequent containment
breaches and while the foundation
mobilized its forces to try to limit the
damage and re-establish containment of
the various anomalies now freed
scp-682 was making its way towards
civilization only to find cactus man the
spiked Menace standing in its path the
Monstrous lizard snarled at the sight of
what it viewed as such a pathetic
adversary even plant life especially a
sentient humanoid plant was an abhorrent
Abomination to
scp-682 civilians were running in Terror
of the hard to destroy reptile as it
made its way through the city
slaughtering any in its path and yet
scp-2800 was standing bravely against it
we both know they'll catch up to you
eventually Daniel called to the monster
as soon as though it'll be right back in
the vat of acid with he I know you're
not a fan of being locked up I'm not
either but you need to go back to your
cage
scp-682 started laughing a roaring
inhuman sound it didn't feel the
part-planed creature was even worth a
verbal response suit yourself pal cactus
man smirked he started calmly walking
towards the Beast as scp-682 began
charging its way through the street
hurtling towards its enemy still
scp-2800 Strode without breaking a sweat
not that a cactus can sweat but whereas
before he would have doubted himself
especially going up against something as
big and ferocious as the hard to destroy
reptile now Daniel was cool and
collected with two seeds in his palm
they quickly grew into round spiked
cacti that covered his clench fists like
boxing gloves with sharp pointed needles
sticking out of them
scp-682 was almost upon him and launched
a vicious swipe with its clawed arm move
moving with speed and the matrix-like
reflexes cactus man easily sidestep the
oncoming blow before 682 had time to
launch another attack 2800 countered
with a kaktakerous counter move he gave
a series of quick Jabs each strike of
his fist Landing with enough strength to
reel the crocodilian creature and leave
sharp spines embedded in its snout the
hard to destroy reptile backed up trying
to create some distance between it and
it's surprisingly strong opponent but
cactus man wasn't about to let this
monster get another chance to attack
raising both arms he fired a volley of
his Cactus spines at the monstrosity The
Barrage of razor sharp needles shredding
through the reptile's flesh more were
regrowing in the place of the ones now
tearing through scp-682 supplying Daniel
with an infinite supply of spikes to
shoot at the reptile as fast as it could
regenerate from the damage suddenly
still being impaled by the bombardment
of needles the crocodilian anomaly gave
a wild flailing swipe of its arm the
monsters claws cleaved ruts into Cactus
Man's Chest the aggressive move caught
him off guard for a split second just
enough time for scp-682 to thrash its
tail and sent him hurtling across the
street cactus man crashed into the
sidewalk with enough Force to crack the
pavement knocking down a Lamppost and
uprooting a fire hydrant water was
spraying up into the air as he tried to
will himself to get back up struggling
with his lack of arms until the cool
spray of water came raining down on
Daniel and instantly he felt rejuvenated
it was stronger and more invigorating
than any sip of coffee or energy drink
on the market absorbing sunlight and
moisture he renewed his literal green
fingers with more newly formed spines
protruding through his
chlorophyll-filled skin in seconds
cactus man was back to full form ready
to end this fight once and for all
turning to face the Sinister scaly
Terror that was scp-682 Daniel nelton
reached his hand into the cracks he had
left in the asphalt his fingers reached
deeper right into the soil below while
scp-682 began to menacingly draw nearer
it charged again only to feel a rumbling
burrowing up through the very Earth
beneath its feet until suddenly
something came bursting up from the
ground sending chunks of Road up into
the air over turning nearby cars with
the force of whatever was exploding Up
From Below sharp piercing pain ripped
through the hard to destroy reptile's
body at multiple points its arms legs
torso were all impaled whatever it was
kept burrowing upwards lifting scp-682
up off the ground as it climbed no grew
out of the earth a gigantic cactus had
sprouted up seemingly out of nowhere it
was huge far bigger than any on record
the size of a large oak tree and still
rapidly growing it spiked branches
reached outwards as it climbed and
climbed pull apart the limbs of scp-682
that were impaled on its enormous
needles separated into several angry
snarling and thrashing pieces the hard
to destroy reptile was bested all the
while scp-2800 was concentrating on
endlessly regrowing the spines of its
miles tall Cactus he had created keeping
scp-682 skewered long enough for the
foundation to move in and recontain the
infamous creature crowds of people had
witnessed the battle and filmed it on
their phones some even live streaming
The Showdown as it happened by the time
the foundation was about to initiate a
cover-up and start administering
amnestics the name Cactus man was
already trending worldwide on social
media news crews flocked to the scene
rushing up to thank scp-2800 for his
heroism people were cheering and
clapping in their gratitude and what's
more when fire Crews and Emergency
Services began tending to those wounded
in The Reptilian Rampage Daniel was seen
aiding them he helped clear Rubble use
using his plant Powers clearing damaged
vehicles and debris from buildings and
offering to help paramedics tend to the
wounded all this while watched by the
adoring eyes of the people he wanted to
save it was too late for the foundation
to step in and sweep this incident under
the rug the whole world had seen cactus
man now and they loved him of course
that didn't stop them from trying to
recontain scp-2800 but when Shady
vehicles and armored MTF troops appeared
to whisk their new hero away people
didn't take kindly to it even while
unaware of who the foundation was or
what they did there was a massive public
outcry for cactus man to be released
from whoever had taken him into custody
the foundation did their best to ignore
it placing Daniel back in his cell for
the time being that was until the
worldwide calls of free cactus man grew
so loud that even the powers that be
started to listen the governments of the
world slowly all started sharing their
own support of the plant-powered hero
who had risked his life for the safety
of ordinary citizens he'd never even met
there were some who blamed the immense
collateral damage caused by his fight
with scp-682 on Daniel himself
especially with the gigantic
skyscraper-sized cactus permanently
standing on the site where the battle
took place however those detractors were
eventually silenced by those with the
growing concern of who would protect
them if an incident like that ever
happened again finally the SCP
Foundation were put under enough immense
unignorable pressure by the governments
of every country that knew of their
existence that there was only one course
of action left the door to Daniel
McIntyre was unlocked and opened for
good and Cactus man was free to go the
world welcomed him with open arms he was
awarded medals for bravery thanks to his
efforts in saving people by fending off
682 cactus man graciously accepted and
offered to help out wherever he could
anywhere in the world over the coming
years working with intelligence and
transport station provided by the
foundation
scp-2800 was sent anywhere and
everywhere wherever there was conflict
or a natural disaster or even another
containment breach the world had a hero
ready and willing to step in people
adored Daniel with many growing
varieties of cacti in their homes to
honor his heroics and just in case he
ever needed backup should the worst
happen cactus man had become a hero
Beyond his own wildest aspirations but
despite being adored and revered the
world over saving lives was never about
fame or recognition to him the fact
remained that Daniel just couldn't help
it even before being put inside scp-914
and refined he had always held doing the
right thing above all else no matter the
impact it had on himself he'd risk his
own safety risk being beaten up injured
or worse if it meant getting another
person out of Harm's Way commendable
some might say but that compulsion never
left him even after ushering in a new
era of Peace
scp-2800 still wanted to help save
people but was there anybody left who
needed him to well there was just one
man one cactus man who still needed
saving now go and check out what if
scp-343 wore scp-035 and what if
scp-1471 Mal o was put inside scp-914
for more weird and wild what-if
scenarios